and i think there's not a lot of um
or at least i should say i don't see a
lot of examples of man talking about
like i did a year of therapy and i'm and
i'm healing and i've got a photo of my
five-year-old self on my phone and i'm
yeah
i don't i don't hear a lot of men
talking like that
not saying i'm better than or you know
more emotionally involved or something i
just think
i'm doing my best to be an example to
show other men that it's okay
and other women that it's also okay to
be with men
who want to do that because i think
what i've learned
from my personal experience of writing
the mask in masculinity
going on tour talking about these topics
of kind of men being more vulnerable men
healing men talking about their emotions
men
expressing themselves in vulnerable ways
and sharing their shame which the when i
grew up was not a thing that you were
allowed to do with a boy or a man
it was really looked down looked down
upon and made fun of you know called the
name all the names that you know you're
called to
make you look weak
and um
it's funny i remember in my last
relationship crying one time
being like very vulnerable
and my girlfriend being like
not being able to handle it like she
couldn't handle me crying and she was
like it just looks like you're really
weak
like i know that's the wrong thing to
say but that's how i feel because it's
how i've been conditioned
yeah you know it's how i've been
conditioned that crying so she never
cried right she
didn't cry because she thought it made
you're weak
and i was just like well i'm going to
keep open if i feel something i'm going
to express it
it's not like i was crying all the time
but there was a few moments when we were
going through some tough stuff and i was
just like here's what i'm going through
what i've witnessed
is
a lot of women saying they want their
their male partner to be vulnerable and
and sensitive and
be more
emotionally
uh flexible
and yet
when
the man is finally like okay i'm gonna
i'm gonna reveal this i'm gonna talk
about my shame and i'm to allow myself
to cry in front of my my wife or my
girlfriend or whatever my partner
i have heard the men tell me that when i
did that the woman shut down like their
partner shut down they couldn't handle
it they're like well i'm freaking out
right now so i need you to be strong so
i'm just trying to do my best
to express myself that way and to and to
take down the stereotypes that you can't
have a photo of your inner child you
know and and do these things as a guy
uh with a platform so that's what i'm
i'm just trying to do my best and as i
figure it out to live by example you do
an incredible job of that i think thank
you i appreciate you it's the reason why
you know my boyfriend's like he seems
he's a great i've heard great things he
seems like a great guy let's have dinner
with him
because you're willing to go there and
he's a very emotionally intelligent and
aware guy himself so
um what do you think like this is more
of like a curiosity
because
you know depending on who you listen to
or talk to or even what you think i mean
people like jordan peterson and stuff
it's like a man should be a man and
there's other people that talk about
this too but like i do think that
there's a difference between men and
women i think i don't think that they're
all identical but i think there's some
generalities of like um
things that the that you're one is a
little better at than the other
absolutely and that it's not about like
in this game of like equality
and it's not to me about it's about
equality and it's not about like
patriarchy shifts in a matriarchy that's
not what i'm here for i'm here for this
this sort of
um
opportunity where we each shine in our
own ways which might mean more than the
other in some ways
but
looking at each other
across
genders or roles with gratitude and
respect
that no matter what that is it doesn't
it's not better or worse and that we all
need what we're good at and when we can
embrace what we're each good at then we
become
a better version of the human race
becomes a better version of itself
it's no longer it's not not in a
contraction mode it's in an expansion
mode
so what is it i'm curious what is it
that you think
a role is for men that you you believe
in your heart and and perhaps even for a
woman what you think a woman does the
best at or is really shines at when we
figure out what our vision is and what
our goals are
then we can figure out how to get there
easier when we are unclear on what a
vision is for our life
then it's going to be unclear on what
our roles and responsibilities are from
my experience i speak from an athletic
background point of view mostly in team
sports you're more of an individual
sport although you had a team
you know working with you but you were
the the driver in the car there wasn't
like five people in the car you know
doing that but you had a team
and i think a basketball
you know it's like
it's five guys on a court and i'm not
going to go up against shaquille o'neal
because that's not my role i'm not a
seven foot you know beast that can take
him on
at a center position
my role would be more of a shooting
guard because of my uniqueness my skills
my talents my physicality all those
things
and if i and if our object of
me playing basketball on a team was to
win the championship that was the vision
we're here to play
we're here to win
this game
not saying that you need to win or lose
in life but for the for the context of
this story
you're going to put your teammates in
the best position in the best roles
possible in order to go go up against
the challenges of life yeah whatever the
challenges of that the other team you're
playing against or the challenges of
life that you're going up against as a
partnership in a relationship
the thing that i
love about my
my girlfriend martha
is that she has a model of
her parents have been married for 40
years and
unless they're fooling all of us they
seem like they're incredibly in love
they
are joking and are playful and loving
and you're kind to one another they're
not you know passive aggressive and
angry and dismissive there's this
but she
her mother has a specific role that she
plays in the relationship that she loves
to play that role because she's
more talented more skilled and a better
fit for
than her her husband her husband plays a
different role that has his unique skill
sets his unique talents
that line up and partner up in a
powerful way
where they respect each of their roles
just like i would respect someone like
shaquille o'neal on my team i couldn't
act like i could have those skills
because i don't
i'm not that skilled type of a player in
basketball i have a different talents
and hopefully he would be able to
respect my skill set on a basketball
court
and in my relationship she loves the
skill set and the rest the uh the role
that i play
in our relationship in my life in my
business and in our relationship and she
loves the role she plays
in our partnership as well because we
have come together when we started
dating
and i said this is what i want this is
my vision for my life
this is what i see my life becoming in
the future
this is where
this is everything i did in my past
where i messed up and made mistakes
i'm going to reveal everything to you
this is where i'm at now and this is
where i'm heading in the future i'm very
clear on my vision
for my relationship future
what i want based on this season of life
and she said this is what i want and
here are my values and my vision we did
exercises we went to sedona and i said
let's do an exercise where you write on
a piece of paper all your values
everything that matters to you
i'm going to write you know on my pieces
of paper in my journal all the things
that matter to me and then we're going
to come unbiased together and see if
they match up about 90 of them matched
up from the things we wanted to do
you know how we wanted to live our life
our lifestyle like all these different
things
and the things that didn't line up i go
are these deal breakers for us sure is
this super important for you
and you need to have this and if i don't
care about that are you okay with it and
there were no deal breakers in terms of
the whatever 10 percent of things that
weren't on the same they were very
similar to what we had already talked
about so i said
even with that we
we still may not work out you know even
though our values are lined up and our
vision seems to be lined up
time will tell over time if we can
play well as a team
just like in basketball you gotta play
well as teammates in order to see if you
can accomplish the goals you have for
that season
and so um
and that takes in my opinion i use
everything with sports analogies
having a great coach and me having a
great coach of my mind and my emotions
and my health and her having a great
coach of her mind her emotions and her
health where we are both accountable
to our
work ethic our energy our attitude on a
basketball team
i've been on teams where some of the
guys are incredible freaks of nature
talented beyond belief could jump out of
the gym dunk shoot run so fast
way better athletes than me
but had horrible work ethic horrible
attitude
and
didn't work together as a team they were
selfish they wanted these things
so they went from starters to on the
bench to being a distraction on the
bench to being kicked off the team even
though they're the best athlete on the
team let that be a lesson so
you've got to be willing to
if you're if you're going to be in a
relationship from you're talking to a
guy who's
failed at every relationship because
they've all ended
and has learned because i chose these
certain relationships and and
and didn't uh step up to my boundaries
and i kept trying when it wasn't the
right fit
because i didn't communicate my values
and my vision early on and i stayed in
for the wrong reasons so i take full
responsibility
now with that wisdom and that clarity
it's
it's easier for me to see it looking
back
because i've gone through that much pain
and frustration for myself
but it's because i have a coach a
therapist
who's allowed me to go through multiple
exercises just like you're talking about
and and experience it be like okay well
moving forward what is it that i really
need i need to play my role
my part
and be clear on my values and my vision
and lifestyle and if the other person
isn't aligned then there's nothing wrong
with that person we're just not the
right fit so don't get committed in the
first place right and that's not
vulnerable early and you're just like
look okay
instead of carrying on and abandoning
yourself which is what ends up happening
by going oh you know we'll just see it's
like you kind of went
stepped up to the plate and went okay
i really like you i know
six months in but here are my here is
like my boundaries i did that i did that
like two and a half months yeah i mean
that's amazing yeah here's something you
might lose them and that's that's the
game right you might being okay
exactly and i think i was never okay
with like losing something yeah
and losing the person losing them loving
me and the connection and the friendship
we built because if it doesn't work out
then maybe we won't speak together and i
was always afraid that i wasn't going to
be enough or that i was going to be
alone or that they would be hurt or they
would judge me or they would think i was
a bad guy because i didn't choose them
and so in this relationship was the most
interesting thing i'd ever done
was a decision i made and um both we
both made and i started reflecting on
all the previous relationships
there was let's say sexual activity
early in every relationship right and
that sexual activity created
a chemical bond of this feels good and
this great connection and
and there was no conversation about
values or vision or lifestyle
we're having fun this is a great time
we're experiencing life together and
we've got this
chemical bond
and
this time i said listen
there's there's not going to be any of
that and um
we can hang out and
and
we spend when i say there wasn't any of
that i mean my friends are like in shock
especially my guy friends
i'm gonna get vulnerable here but it's
almost three months i spent 40 nights
next to her without without that
activity going on and um
talk about self-discipline for me as
someone who's driven by you know who
wants that a lot
sure i was just like it's not worth it
it's not worth it until i find out like
where this is going and if we are in
alignment on our values and our vision
which you could call
roles and responsibilities towards your
vision in life
and so again
i feel great right even with all this
happening it doesn't mean like
it's going to be happy forever or ever
it's just a realistic version who knows
who knows what can happen but i feel the
most at peace it feels incredible and i
feel like i'm laying a foundation
break after break of possibilities of
something greater
than
doing the things in reverse that i've
always done so it's it's been a
beautiful experience but it was not easy
and i had to break certain habits so